cyril hanouna
bon ça commence à un petit pas se voir
quand même un entrepôt quand zemmour va
falloir faire poser un petit peu un
moment donné parce que franchement tous
les jours y a pas une journée où on n'a
pas parlé de zemmour sur touche pas à
mon poste c'est incroyable une
propagande j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
alors balances ton post sur le racisme
anti-blanc la semaine d'un bond jordan
bardella messi à tous les jours du lundi
au dimanche zemmour et pourquoi tu as
voté pour zemmour et pourquoi tu parais
seymour et pourquoi tu donnes 10 euros à
zemmour un moment donné et faut
s'arrêter quoi alors c'était la vidéo de
danas alors bon on va lui répondre à ce
non non mais c'est sûr mais moins ici à
la fin plus et et moi je suis pour le
dialogue il sait qu'il invitait souvent
ici moi cette vidéo elle m'a fait un peu
de pub de ce qu'un aspect connais bien
je l'invitais jetèrent des premiers à
l'invité des grandes gueules aussi qui
l'on avait avec qui travailler et c'est
vrai que eric zemmour nous ont pas de
l'actualité eric zemmour il se trouve qu
eric zemmour tous les soirs et une
actualité qui me parle de gens mais
ciani soir raquel garrido el ela un
pratiquement de soir en soir déjà le
mans b olive olivella pratiquement aussi
très souvent serré que nous on essaie de
donner la parole à tout le monde la
sueur sur eric zemmour eric zemmour il
neigera encore venu de rémission alors
on va certainement le recevoir mais pas
en visio je crois déjà en visio
exactement dans une vidéo une vidéo de
fait une vidéo mais tu es venu plus
souvent qu eric zemmour gilles et autant
ça parce que moi ça me fait un peu de
peine parce que vous deviez ça ne touche
pas parce que c'est complètement faux
parce que vraiment nous traite de
l'actualité demain je vais vous dire
demain vous répondra mais demain il va
voir jean luc mélenchon je te jure jean
luc mélenchon il a fait beaucoup plus
d'antennes chez nous que eric zemmour
c'est ça rien à voir sans commune mesure
parce que j'ai dit après le mot
propagande voilà il est dégueulasse et
en plus cela vous nos blessés c'est
alors vous nous considérer comme quoi
comme des porte parole de zemmour vous
considérez que on est là pour lui cirer
les pompes alors que ici on dit ce qu'on
veut exactement totalement et c'est vrai
qu'on est doit tendre avec lui indiquons
exactement sans aucune censure aucune
interdiction et moi par exemple je suis
extrêmement sévère avec avec ses mots et
jamais on m'a dit tu es toi donc dire ça
je trouve que c'est mépriser les
missions nous mépriser nous c'est pas
très grave méprise et cyril et méprisé
tous les gens qu'il garda tard et là je
trouve que là vraiment vous ne dépassez
les bornes la planète entière non quand
même pas comme la nasa mais tous les
gens qui regardent non nous sentir bien
après voilà j'ai pas d'influencé je ne
sais pas non plus un drame mais c'est
pas non plus un drame voilà ce
qu'annonce ses profits c'est dégueulasse
et ses lieux ses portes après travaux
répondent anas parce qu'il est là c'est
bien qu'ils nous répondent oui bon ça
m'a commandé deux mois c'est le propre
et moi seul bémol ce que génère plus
qu'il l'océana je les aime bien ce
qu'elle considérait ces vaccins c'est
vrai que c'est la vérité que tout le
monde par deux et moi que ça le dérange
sache peut l'entendre mais qui parle de
propagande concernant tpm paix non c'est
pas possible parce que beaucoup
voulaient pas qu'on a tous des avis
d'ouverture cessé quand on fait la
propagande c'est qu'on est pour
quelqu'un et qu'on fait de la propagande
tacon le promu est content ce qu'il faut
encore mieux ils veulent nous répondent
après un assez sûrs d'eux me dois de
répondre là dessus guillaume moi votre
vidéo je les trouvais intéressante sur
le fond parce que c'est vrai que c'est
un sujet est-ce qu'il faut parler de
dingue voilà maintenant sur la forme
j'ai l'impression que c'était une pure
provocation pour faire le buzz j'avais
un bingo de tout ce qui marche de tout
ce qui fait parle en ce moment eric
zemmour tpm pc d'hanouna propagande et
la preuve vous avez gagné puisque vous
êtes là ce soir pour en parler j'ai
l'impression que c'était que c'est privé
qui ce qui est si je voulais avoir une
discussion avec lui mais voilà bien et
que voilà je n'en veux pas je dis la
vérité je ne veux pas du tout
que vous lui avez donné que mme bardon
mais la parole une dizaine de fois vous
êtes là pour justement pour un fond bien
ordonnées vont me vignon et votre boss
qu'il est intéressant c'est un
sacristain de la paroisse qui était la
mère l'a donc vous pouvez pas d'élection
c'est plein progrès pas du tout d abord
je venais la parole et c'est quelqu'un
qui répond je peux répondre sur alizé
and haas mais je te dis voilà je suis
moi je te dis moi je te donne la parole
parce que je trouve intéressant et je
trouve que tu rates à une vf façon de
penser une vision de la france qui est
intéressante et qui ont conduit à
écouter est donc tout à fait ta place
dans mes émissions et je regrette pas du
tout avoir donné à paroles et je te la
re donnerait autant de fois que tu le
désires à ça c'est le même c'est il est
aussi dangereux que zemmour voilà bon
c'est vous qui dites voilà la phrase
sait pas qui est dangereux
seymour anaska zip a pour l'instant on
va voir mais c'est vrai que voilà vous
aussi vous êtes dangereux rendre les
gens et les envoyer enfin bon c'est un
milieu aussi il est dangereux sais pas
si vous avez vu le dernier vidéo gag
mollo l'asticot ah oui enfin bref juste
juste déjà est-ce que j'ai été invité
dix fois chez cyril hanouna non c'est 5
6 fois du convoi on va les cités parce
qu'il y en a pas des masses j'ai fait
une émission face à sonia mabrouk j'ai
fait une émission face à jean messia
j'ai été invité
face à claire o'petit sur balance
compost et j'ai été invité avec plein
d'autres grévistes le 5 décembre la
chevasse a donc c'est déjà quasiment est
aujourd'hui 5 aujourd'hui attendez de
petit secret party della scienza les
avionnais je ne fais pas cas très bien
madame sonia del valle ils ont pu alors
je ne fais pas de je ne fais pas de buzz
parce que si vous demandez à la prod la
prod2 m'a demandé insisté plusieurs fois
jour venir oui vous les trouviez de ce
soir voilà le refuser de venir ou alors
je vais m'expliquer pourquoi la première
chose par rapport à cette vidéo déjà
c'est une vidéo qu 99 fois sur 100 je
poste bas parce qu'elle est dans le noir
chez dans ma bagnole le son est même pas
terrible mais cette vidéo là moi je suis
suivi par qui en gros sur twitter
instagram j'ai à peu près 50 1000
followers cette vidéo elle fait
quasiment huit cent mille vu rennes sur
mes réseaux sans parler des partages
donc déjà vous ici ça devrait vous posez
une interrogation de qu'est-ce qui fait
qu'une vidéo dans le noir on voit rien
du tout qui fait 2 minutes 20 qui parle
d'un sujet
jamais vu sur la vidéo j'ai écouté avec
une attention s'il vous plaît juste pour
qu'on allait vous avez qu'on a dit anas
va nous parler pas que de tels que de
tpm pg parler tpm paix parce que y'a un
moment donné il faut juste regarder qui
a été invité ne tombez pas dans le truc
de dire à neuf est venu plus que des
mots parce que anas les quatre émissions
de télé 5 mai les les cinq émissions de
télé vous savez combien j'en ai fait
cette année démission alors que je suis
candidat à la présidentielle que j'ai
plus de 100 parrainages j'en ai fait
trois d'accord j'ai fait trois émissions
de télé dans toute l'année mais bon je
sais dit de la rive allemande quand je
vous ai dit de propagande c'est à dire
que en boucle en boucle au quotidien
c'est pas dire et moore était assise à
tpm p ça veut dire que quand vous avez
messier a qui vient et qui vit des
trains mais mes soutiens et messieurs
médias glacial raquel garrido
mais un bon gros d'aviron excellent
maire cyril hanouna soyons pas
démagogique il ya un basculement vers
l'extrême droite de l'ensemble des
médias des données non mais alors c'est
vrai
je peux le défend mais chez nous chez
nous aussi vous trouvez je sais ce que
c'est bien du tout j'arrive g arrive
juste à les voires rudy juste laissez
moi juste terminer une phrase et vous
allez comprendre ce que je suis en train
de raconter l'extrême droite à commence
à avoir de plus en plus pignon sur rue
je l'assumé je le dis pour moi la pointe
avancée de cette de ce discours
médiatique c'est la chaîne c'est nous
quand vous voyez le nombre
d'éditorialistes elisabeth lévy dassier
vient une fois dans les films où tout
arrêter
là vous il n'est pas des primaires
revient sur pet en paix mon monteur
temps pareil n'est pas décompté hervé
qu'elle tende n'ont aucune injustice que
je trouve plaisir des croûtes montant
paroles aient plaisir pendant
le chantier
permet d'acheter noah il nous reste une
vie des mois s'il reste une minasse
discussion
c'est patrick sébastien si vous vous ne
voyez pas j'avais donné la c1 monopolise
à retourner des séries donne et comptes
en euros la preuve en est que quand je
parle de propagande zemmour aujourd'hui
on a parlé encore une fois de zemmour
dans le monde s'est réjoui
en parler de vous oui c'est ça à nador
dans l'option prévue au thon meeting
excusez-moi gilles verdez vous
posez-vous là vous êtes journaliste
également gilles verdez oui je
n'agissais water je suis candidat à la
présidence john justin est rétabli
combien j'étais en tête j'ai compté
depuis avril d'accord qu'eric zemmour il
est même pas il émane à cela il doit se
rendre chez tva serait
télécommunicateurs dida la
présidentielle c'est la première fois en
fait qu'un ouvrier issus de
l'immigration porte sa candidature il y
avait plus plus de 450 personnes en
réalité on a vu au moins 500 parce que
dans les couloirs c'était bondé il n'y a
pas eu une un micro ya pas une caméra
hésitante durant ma maison
j'ai reçu au moins deux mesures mais
c'est bien le message d'erreur c'est la
mêlée on a le droit de venir ici vous
dites ces lycées venir pourquoi pouvoir
d'agir
parler à ses caprices et vous
qu'avez-vous sergas marché
tendu le part d'officiers
[Applaudissements]